[Music]
we don't have adequate amount of space
for the people at Max we possibly can
get 100 people in our mosque
at one time as you can see the alleyway
is dirty we are praying next to very
much
uh sharp objects at times it's a health
and safety risk for many we've got
children attending prayer uh
alhamdulillah we are in a very blessed
location our location is very Central to
many many many places but it's just
we're in a very constricted area so
please people don't forget
and obviously after Allah
his success he has placed you know the
people
those who have you know amount of money
inshallah whatever it may be smaller big
to donate generously so we hope that you
all don't forget us you know donations
as well as your eyes your supplications
may God bless you before anything that
you can carry on to supplicate for us
and donate immensely and genuinously and
let's not forget the reality of the
Mischief the Masjid is the heart for
every Community for every Muslim
Community the Masjid is some place where
we can all attend an all effective go to
in order to cure ourselves if any you
know spiritual issues and also to gain
closeness to our Lord Allah Allah
[Music]
lighter
Allah
foreign
[Music]